it is an incredible view that we have
here being able to look at the screen
and see all of the faces of people
around the world and it's inspiring that
you could run an event like this online
[Music]
what a great group thank you so much for
all participating I just want to say
that you have actually transformed my
view of virtual education men I mean it
has been an experience over the years
that is totally memorable and
unforgettable you can do anything that's
truly authentic to you and your
strengths and your interests and
passions and it will serve the world
[Music]
thank you so much I'm speechless and I'm
trying the revelation was that you could
actually form a community of people who
were from all around the world in
different time zones completely spread
at geographically dispersed but yet who
would become a whole that was more than
the sum of the parts community is such a
special one and I know that a lot of you
feel this way as well thanks to all of
you and Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]